hey guys this episode idea was by Jayla
Alexis Thank You Jayla make sure you
stick around to the very end because
we've got a big announcement until then
enjoy the episode a girl can feel yet
more masculine doesn't mean she's not a
girl so then me being born may of
biologically male would you say I'm 100%
male hi my name is kaity el amor and I'm
a writer and I believe that God designed
us with purpose and that beautiful love
story is in our DNA hi my name is
Natalie I'm actually in commercial real
estate but I'm very excited to show this
discussion with you guys hi guys my name
is Rebecca I'm a student and I'm looking
forward to talking about gender and
hearing what you guys think hey my name
is Rory my gender is non-binary and I
use they/them there's pronouns hi my
name is Satine and I am a trans woman I
work in film and television as makeup
artist hi my name is Marcus I identify
as a transgender male and I'm really
excited to have this discussion with you
guys
the reason why I feel like girls and
boys should be raised the same I'm
saying just raising them to be
upstanding citizens in society and
things like that exactly not to say that
like gender doesn't exist but to give
young people an ability to navigate that
themselves to come into themselves I
actually agree with a lot of your points
as far as there are a lot of
similarities between boys and girls
growing up and I believe that all
children should be raised in a loving
supportive family but I think that there
does need to be balance and just some of
the characteristics that men and women
have where it's like women usually are
more nurturing with boys they want to
grow up and like what does it mean to be
a man and what does it mean to be a
provider what does it mean to lead your
family and those are the things that are
traditional to me where I feel like the
man is the head of the household I grew
up being a tomboy like I am so so
connected to my masculine side and so
much to my feminine side I really feel
50-50 and I feel like in our society now
when a girl is is raised and she feels
like a tomboy acts like a tomboy she's
now encouraged to kind of think maybe I
should have been born as a guy but for
me it's always been oh maybe she's just
interested in things that guys typically
like and that's fine you can still be a
girl and be interested in that and you
can still embrace being a girl yeah
piggyback off of what you're saying as a
little girl I always only wanted to shop
in the boys section of course my family
was completely against it I grew up in a
religious family I'm actually creative
Angelico Christian myself but my family
would use my tomboi statement to write
it off and minimize the fact that no I
actually really don't like being a girl
sometimes like you said there's actually
genuine Tom Blais in the world with me
no that wasn't it was way more than that
and it can be very difficult for parents
to make that distinction oh because when
you're a young child it's hard to
express how you're feeling inside and
especially like as like a freaking
eight-year-old I had no idea what
transgender was I didn't know any of
that but that's that's what's really
important I don't think as it
year-old you should know that label you
know I mean I don't think we should know
labels period your DNA is going to be
the same from when you're born and until
you die and it doesn't matter how you
dress yourselves or what hormones you
take I mean you're either going to be a
male or a woman you have those
chromosomes in your body there are
certain things about yourself that are
gonna stay the same your whole life and
you have to accept those and and embrace
them because if you don't embrace them
you're just gonna be hating yourself I
really wanted to be normal like that
there's nothing in life I've ever wanted
more than to be normal that's the
problem that is the problem I run into
it but it doesn't really exist and I
every attempt that I've made to try and
be more like one gender or the other
hasn't really worked so finally I just
got to a place where I was like well
people may say that there isn't anything
in-between
but I am in between you know and I feel
like the people who really know me and
love me they see that it's it's
difficult to think that there could only
be two like how is that how would that
even be possible when there's like on a
spectrum of like masculinity and
femininity okay don't you lie anywhere
well it's like the tomboy idea that a
girl can feel and have these yeah more
masculine doesn't mean she's not a girl
there's a spectrum but there's two
definitive parts to the spectrum so then
would you okay
well with me being born male of
biologically male would you say I'm 100%
male well you made the transition so you
didn't feel like are you physically born
as a male but you would you say I'm 100%
female I'll be honest and say I feel on
I use the chromosome but I would say you
are under a hundred percent a
that would just be my belief you're 100%
what you're portraying to me and because
I'm that Who am I decide that for you
wouldn't that mean that I am somewhere
on this gender spectrum not necessarily
one or the other which is the binder
scientifically you are one thing and
you'll always be a male scientifically
you can express yourself however you
want to the world and hopefully the
world accepts you for who you want to be
and who you are but when it comes to the
spectrum I mean there are not that many
transgender people in this world when it
comes down to in LA there are there's a
bigger population just so you ladies all
your lives you don't even know how many
hands you should that was possibly a
trans person the reason why you don't
see it is because those trans
individuals don't want you to see it in
middle of America they don't have the
same like opportunities and great laws
as Californians so it's just like well I
better lie low before like I give my ass
beep somewhere
I feel kind of this is another one that
I feel a little split about I on one
hand with all of my heart
have respect for again like I said
before whatever you feel you should live
you know however with that said if I had
a little girl and if you're not
completely transitioned you don't want
them to be expressive that maybe not yet
maybe not yet that is right have you
thought about what that person might be
going through how scared they probably
are that they're being judged as they go
in before I transition when I was still
confused as to what I wanted to do and
who I was and it was really difficult
but I decided to use the women's
restroom so because I did not feel safe
in the men's restroom and I knew that I
would not be a problem it takes a lot of
courage that people don't understand it
really hurts your psyche I would say for
a safety I do agree that you should be
able to go where you feel comfortable
however the line that I would draw is if
we were one day to say all bathrooms
should be just open for anybody to touch
on that point I've been at gyms where
it's like a restroom and a locker room
and people are changing there it can be
difficult because when the rules start
to get so relaxed like that where a guy
that wanted to go in a woman's locker
room that wasn't transgender and then if
anybody questioned him he can just say I
feel like a woman that's you know and
that's a concern for me it's interesting
how we get so hung up on on trans folks
in bathrooms when it seems like the
underlying fear might be that men are
predators and that we are afraid
predatory men either posing as trans
women or just in general having
gender-neutral restrooms maybe if
they're not all the restrooms but some
restrooms that are gender neutral would
just be good for everybody's safety I
agree
[Music]
to come and tell me you know we're gonna
be born and I'm just gonna decide what
I'm gonna be I'm sorry that's a crock of
to me I believe that first yeah
you're born your woman our man I believe
that gender shouldn't be based on
feelings because our feelings change a
lot not everybody's does I understand
that but a majority of people do as they
grow up you said the word decide I did
not like wait till 18 and decide I'm
gonna be a man today everything in my
power I did not actually want to be
transgender the decision that I made was
being authentically me to be happy
that's to me it was be happy or
eventually commit suicide
the thing about gender is you don't
choose your gender or your gender is
something that develops over time it's
very fluid there's no denying that I
mean I was born male no denying but you
know my government paper is all safe
female because that's who I am
one thing that I want to know were you
raised in like a conservative household
did you any of you have the ability to
actually sit down and talk to your
parents and like ask any questions
I didn't start transitioning until I was
32 I didn't come out to my dad until I
was 33 and that I couldn't I come from a
very conservative family but he didn't
want to lose my dad
when you think you might lose something
that you love it's really hard to go
forward and make that decision
[Music]
everyone that's born on this earth is
special and we're all lucky to be alive
and be on this planet and have the
opportunity to experience our lives and
experience love and I'm not going to be
influencing them and saying no this is
the right way of living you have to live
this way but I'm gonna say you need to
carefully consider really think about
and think about the social implications
as well and everything that you're gonna
have to face if you go through that is
it worth it for you
I feel like support and acceptance are
different things so if it wasn't
something I agree with what I love them
would I be there for them when I support
them would I have the conversations yes
what I say I agree with you no see I
grew up with the acceptance part and
that hurt kind of more for me I I felt
like she was only accepting me because
she gave birth to me but if she didn't
give birth to me it's like no you went
yeah and that and I didn't like that
feeling you know if I had grown up in a
place where I felt loved and accepted
unconditionally I think that I would
have saved myself a lot of therapy and a
lot of self work but you know maybe we
don't know for certain yet and the best
we can do I think is is keep trying I
think that even with this discussion it
drives the point home about how
important family is how important love
is how important it is to really support
no matter how you feel or how you're
raised like this world can really break
you down so that's why for me like
family is so important I think it's a
beautiful thing and I think that we
should be doing a better job in raising
our children and loving on them
[Music]
guys thanks for watching another episode
of middle ground the reason we do this
is to create a movement for human good
and we have a special announcement we're
starting our own clothing line and guess
what it's called it's called good human
and we want this just to be the physical
embodiment of dialogue and empathy so
get on board that's right you can learn
more about good human which is the name
of the brand down below as always guys
we can't thank you enough make sure to
subscribe follow us on Instagram and
we'll see you next time